[Musique]
j'ai ouvert le jardin pour renouveler la
clientèle de la galerie aussi parce que
il ya eu beaucoup de demandes pour que
j'ouvre mon jardin et de source c'est
venu capacité normale qu'on mette des
oeuvres à l'extérieur
dans un jardin c'est c'est quelque chose
qui semble naturel et ça effectivement
peut apporter quelque chose en plus au
jardin mais ça apporte surtout plus à
l'oeuvre parce que l ai vu tout seul y'a
pas il n'ya pas dix sculptures côte à
côte
[Musique]
c'est une oeuvre d'un artiste américain
qui s'appelle larry mc laughin un
artiste très connu qui est mondialement
connu qui vit la plupart du temps aux
états unis mais aussi dans le berry il
s'est acheté une petite maison dans le
berry
il fait là c'est les dernières c'est du
vestiaire donc c'est un
un mélange de sable de béton de chaux
sur une armature et puis là il a
symbolisé la laine du mouton avait des
détails de faire
c'est une oeuvre blanche et sur la
verdure on la voit bien donc elle
ressort on peut pas on peut pas passer à
côté alors on la regarde à prendre garde
les plantes mais on revient parce que on
veut voir les détails
les oeuvres nous appartiennent pas du
tout c'est lui dépôt pour qu'on en prend
soin comme
comme si c'était quelque chose
d'extrêmement précieux parce que les
artistes et s'attendre quand il pose une
oeuvre trouvait dans le même état alors
simplement dans un jardin il ya un
risque il est un petit peu de couleur
verte s'installe dessus et c'est pas
grave parce que ça se lave très bien
mais ça donne de la patine et
quelquefois l'oeuvre gagne à avoir cette
patine du jardin dessus
l'artiste doit avoir des garanties
décennales comme un bâtiment il ya
beaucoup de gens d'artistes qui ne
savent pas ça donc quand ils créent une
oeuvre qui est capable de rester à
l'extérieur il faut qu'elles tiennent
dans le temps la seule chose que moi je
demande à mes clients c'est que quand
ils vivent dans les régions où le climat
est très très bas avec la pierre il vaut
mieux l'hiver la protéger comme une
plante
[Musique]
xinhua car
le milliard et
[Musique]